si depuis six mois téhéran vit au rythme
des manifestations à paris aussi on se
mobilise ses étudiants terre ce sont de
toutes les actions contre le régime de
leur pays aujourd'hui ces opérations
affichage sur les vitrines d'iranair
est pour yashar qui mène le cortège le
mot d'ordre est toujours le même
alors contre la peine de mort à bas la
dictature
préfet en personne ses premières qui est
symbole même fourni de la dictature
ces mouvements associatifs where is my
vote comité indépendant contre la
répression des citoyens iraniens
si ces policiers sont plutôt
bienveillant c'est qu'ils savent ces
militants surveillé de près par les
agents de l'ambassade d'iran à paris
l'intimidation qui n'a pas de prise sur
ses opposants résolus
nous dire de nos parents et a demandé
aux ministères de renseignement
iranienne là bas on l'aura fait écrire
des choses donc en quoi leurs enfants
elle a arrêté d'être opposant au régime
en france où haiti's allard était de
participer aux manifestations
mais bon ça tout ça c'est plutôt les
dernières soupire
de ce dictature qui tombe mais le régime
vit encore les prises de position de
yachir lui valent de plus pouvoir mettre
les pieds en iran lice il se définit
comme un observateur d'un mouvement qui
n'a qu'une seule tête la jeunesse
le vrai noyau de ce mouvement ce sont
des jeunes qui ont aujourd'hui 20 ans
qui pendant les première deuxième année
pâques c'est vraiment un kyste est en
train de construire ce mouvement est qui
qui sont les instigateurs on va guère
d'autres mouvements en iran près de 70%
de la population a moins de 30 ans c'est
cette jeunesse qui la première est
descendu dans la rue après la réélection
truquée du président ahmadinejad le 12
juin dernier où est passé mon vote
scande-t-elle en anglais histoire se
faire entendre à l'international la
république islamique les jeunes fondeurs
du mouvement vert en ont soupé ils ont
grandi avec après trente ans de
répression il offre au régime une
résistance rugueuse qui fédère
l'opposition politique et religieuse
dans la rue des pavés dans leur chambre
des claviers sur le net ils cassent les
filtres installés par l'état
les lettres persanes de l'ère numérique
passe désormais par la toile en quelques
clics le monde découvre la brutalité
d'un régime qui n'hésitent pas à tirer
dans la foule
si nous solidariser ce sont les gens de
facebook il omet la photo de ma tante et
mon cousin à la classe tu leur fais tu
pour dire arrêtez de arrêter les gens
l'attend le cousin et le frère de ben
amor sont actuellement en prison en iran
bas aurait étudié à paris depuis deux
ans l'histoire de sa famille résume à
elle seule l'iran moderne d ieu engagé
dans toutes les luttes un oncle
assassiné dans les purges de 88 et en
juin dernier son cousin ce robe 19 ans
tué lors des manifestations d'après
élections alors à plus de 4000 km de
distance et la culpabilité qui la ronge
moi j'ai honte thème être et c'est
vraiment j'entrais maîtrise et je ne
peux pas voir des images mais mes
compatriotes je ne peux pas voir je ne
peux pas entendre les nouvelles de ma
famille d'être ici dans un telle liberté
donc pas vraiment il faut rentrer ballaz
c'est là une balade
voilà c'est pas ma place
repéré par les autorités iraniennes lors
de manifestations parisiennes bas or
c'est que si le pouvoir ne change pas de
mains là bas elle ne reverra pas sa
famille avant quelques années
comme barreur madior 20 ans et condamnés
à l'exil échoué ici depuis six mois ils
demandent l'asile politique pourtant la
politique lui il s'en fout son tort en
iran jouer de la musique tendance hip
hop électro et ses dernières
compositions n'ont pas été franchement
du goût de l'état iranien la bo des
chats persans films récemment sortis en
france qui raconte les galères d'un
groupe de rock à téhéran c'est lui
courir le monde façon artistes
accueillir son ami jo dj à berlin un
rêve qu'il aurait préféré réaliser
autrement
on se serait jamais rencontré si tu
n'avais pas été obligé de partir c'est
terrible mais il ya du bon dans le
mauvais la vie continue et j'adorerais
aller à thé en
moi quand je rencontre des gens vraiment
cool comme jo
je n'arrête pas de penser qu'un jour je
les ferai venir pour un concert à
téhéran découvrir ma ville mes amis
faire plein de trucs fumée de la bonne
herbe
mais je sais pas si ça se produira
bientôt
qu'ils soient artistes étudiants aux
responsables politiques à chaque crise
paris est une terre d'élection pour les
dissidents iraniens yashar nous emmène
rue des entrepreneurs dans le xvème
celle que l'on appelle plus vraiment
little terran vibre tout de même encore
discrètement au rythme persan lab se
trouve la vieille garde de la diaspora
iranienne comme l'épicier monsieur ali
20 ans après avoir fui la république
islamique il sait que la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui va lui offrir son ticket
de retour
la jeunesse va faire gagner je pense pas
je suis
on a déjà gagné
je pense 0,1 dans un an vous prenez un
billet au fond ce pur produit j'ai
réservé déjà
un nom est ce que cela suffira de
téhéran a paris il faudra toute la
détermination d'une génération pour
renverser un régime à la main de fer qui
a déjà fait près de 80 morts depuis le
mois de juin dernier